il n'était pas question pour moi de
communiquer à nouveau sur cette
information judiciaire et si je vous ai
demandé de venir ce soir ce n'est pas
dans l'idée de participer à cette
surenchère médiatique
ce n'est pas non plus rassuré vous pour
vous donner vous donner à la presse en
général et à d'autres des leçons de
déontologie ou de morale je n'en n'ai ni
la compétence ni le pouvoir quand bien
même j'en aurai l'envi je voulais juste
vous faire part tout de même de mon
souhait de voir la justice reprendre la
place qui est la sienne celle que vous
lui aviez au cours de ces trois derniers
mois
laisser prendre en permettant aux
enquêteurs de faire la lumière et dieu
sait s'ils l'ont fait avec grand talent
sur ce meurtre et dont interpellé
l'auteur présumé
l'information ne s'arrête pas là
d'autres investigations doivent être
effectués loin de cette terrible
pression à l'abri de ce qui la polluent
la détourne du chemin de la recherche de
la vérité à l'abri de ces violations
répétées et inadmissibles du secret de
l'instruction ni les enquêteurs ni le
juge d'instruction ne peuvent prendre la
parole pour défendre leur travail
alors puisque la loi le permet c'est moi
procureur de la république qui la prend
pour porter la voix de la raison
au milieu de cette folie médiatique qui
oublient que derrière cette histoire
qu'on déroule de manière aussi
indécentes
ce jeu le destin d'un homme qui doit
bénéficier de la présomption d'innocence
bafouée chaque jour depuis son
interpellation le rappeler qu'il a le
droit de modifier ses déclarations de
les préciser
de les ajuster et ce tout au long et
jusqu'à l'issue de l'information
judiciaire
la présomption d'innocence que l'on
bafoue c'est aussi son procès que l'on
fixe déjà son profil psychologique que
l'on évalue et c'est aussi lorsqu'il est
affirmé qu'il sera déjà condamné et que
la date de son procès est quasiment fixé
juste rappeler juste rappeler à tous
ceux qui vous regardent à tous ceux qui
doivent croire en la justice et savoir
ce qu'elle représente que cette valeur
fondamentale de la présomption
d'innocence du secret de l'instruction
ne se marchande pas et puis cette
affaire enfin c'est aussi une jeune
femme morte il ya si peu de temps dans
des conditions terribles et dont la
mémoire est chaque jour salit un peu
plus c'est tout ce que j'avais à vous
dire